It's possible to share the transcript for us, 'cause I need to have those in my site as my record.
Sure.
Key.
At.
Let me share my screen and show you something.
It's a recent complaint from our client.
The ticket was open.
When open 55 at 245, and it assigned to one of our technicians, which, yeah, we started communication with that user, and 'cause it was after five.
It assigned to.
This guy.
Which is OK, and what happened is, during the process, he made a decision to escalate it to escalation, which is OK, 'cause you know, when we when we when they have no workaround or solution to fix the issue, there they should.
The escalated to escalation team, but what happened is in the communication that he sent to user, he mentioned something here, like say the preliminary troubleshooting steps have.
Already been completed.
I'm going to back to the communication that we had with user and see which troubleshooting steps have done. Let's go down.
go down to the original request.
The request was, I'm working at home and printer and there is an issue. Someone who family are fixed the issue for me.
If I go up, what we did was our technician communicated with them, said, I received the ticket for an investigation. We do that once I receive your availability, which is okay. And then they said, I'm available now. It was 454.
The technician said, I tried to call you on this number, but the company is already closed, which is fine. And then it assigned to this guy. What preliminary steps we have done that you mentioned here? Nothing. Why have you mentioned it to user?
Why we mentioned to user and say the preliminary troubleshooting steps have already been completed, which which happened, which steps we did for them, and it caused an issue for us. It caused the issue for us. We shouldn't mention anything that we didn't do that.
It.
And.
Reza, could you please scroll down? I just want to read his notes for between 5 to 24.
Yeah.
And is this a home printer?
Yeah, it is. Regardless of the type of issue, regardless of the issue, I'm just focusing on the way that we communicate with them, the way that we explain things. If we did something, definitely we should let them know that, yeah.
Mhm.
We have done this for you. We couldn't fix it or we could fix it. If we didn't do anything, shouldn't explain it to them.
Yes.
Got it.
Yeah. And it's not a technical part. It's only about the way that technician should think and make a decision to how to communicate with clients.
So it's a nice communication. I love it, but it's not reality.
And it's not only about this guy. I see a couple of things, but I wanted to reiterate the communication part based on this. If I say there is a communication issue with these technicians, I don't want to mention only this guy. Yeah.
When I say there is a communication issue, I mean...
No, no issue on the email that they sent, no issue on the type of email, no issue on the writing. The issue is on the the main purpose of sending that email or matching it with the the reality.
We should be accurate with them.
Even if we couldn't fix the issue, we're gonna let them, yeah, we couldn't fix the issue, and we're gonna escalate it to escalation team.
Key.
Ah, Karine, hi. Oh, hi, Amit, you're here.
Hi, Tanim. Hey, guys. Sorry for joining late. I was doing some scheduling. I had to get caught up on first.
I told him.
Ariza Patel.
I think Arkadi said he was going to be late. He should hopefully join soon. I know he had some stuff going on this morning too.
But.
Okay, anything you have for us, Ashish, Amit, Remy?
Yep, yes. So yeah, thank you so much, Reza, for sharing this. I would check this with Bunch to understand what happened here and why did he write the preliminary troubleshooting steps there. So I will take care of this one.
OK.
Other than that, any other feedback or concerns that you have?
Kip.
Yeah, I have some other stuff. Let me share again my screen if you want.
S.
Sure.
Be financed.
Give me a second.
Okay, let me share my screen again.
Oh, here is another ticket.
Ohh, the ticket to pan based on a call, I think.
Beep.
A request was about installing Tax Pre.
2025 installation software, which is a normal software that we install for the accounting firm. And I see some, I see a couple of notes here, these notes.
Uhh.
Explain that user want this action completed was this, if I wanna if I wanna be accurate about this steps when user ask for tax Pre installation, why we should?
have Dell drivers and BIOS setting. Why we, when they mentioned about HP printer driver, when they mentioned about VPN connectivity, these are AI. These are all AI. These are all AI. I don't want to say that they shouldn't use AI. Definitely they should.
They should use AI, but AI is our tool. It's not for mentioning something in the ticket, which is not useful. Even it's not useful, it's useless. It's a confusion point for us, for the next technician to handle it.
Did you really check the Adobe update? Did you really check the Dell driver on BIOS? How did you check that? How did you go to and check the BIOS setting while you didn't communicate with user? How you, who mentioned about HP printers? Who mentioned about VPN connectivity? They asked for tax per installation only.
And we do have we do have a process for that. I don't want to blame anyone, but what I'm saying is if we have a tools and we want to use the tools, we should make sure about the tool. Yeah, it's good that if you want to use AI, go ahead and use AI, but AI is your tool.
You should make sure what you wrote in a ticket, what you communicate. Yeah, this is important. And again, I see here, we ask us to fill out the information, which is good. These are information that we have as a template. Do you really think these are useful?
Yep.
for the technician that we escalated the ticket to? No, it's only confusion point for them. And the next technician who is Blaze, totally confused about, okay, what that helped this tech.
Kip.
successfully updated Adobe application. How did you do that?
Mm.
How did you do that? I don't see any comment that you connected to the user computer. How did you do that?
These are not based on our process. Installed and configured successfully. How did you do that? No, there is no way.
I cannot rely on this kind of comment.
So.
I don't use machine if I need, if I need, if I needed AI. I've never ever hired someone use AI. I have better AI in this system than GPT. This is my AI. If I click here, I can see a lot of things regarding this. This ticket is gonna find a whatever I want.
And it's accurate. It's more accurate than those things that people put from GPT there.
Kip.
When showing the previous tickets as well.
Yeah, it shows everything. It shows everything. But it's not important now. What's important is we should make sure if they use AI, we should rely on the actions. We should rely on the comments.
And they say action completed. I don't, I don't know why they mentioned something here like this. Confirmed active and working, complete this, install this, BIOS update, complete manual. How you did that, how you updated BIOS.
Just explain it to me how you did that.
And even white required.
It seemed to be a copy paste from what they got from GPT or whatever tool they may have used, right? Or probably, yeah, which is...
Yeah, yeah, definitely. We don't, we don't need, we don't need GPT. We have, we have, we have GPT, we have Premium GPT, we have Cloud, we have Perplexity, we have GM and all this stuff that we already have here. We need technician, we need their thinking, we need their...
It.
Yeah.
Expertise, we need their technical skills.
And I have to back to client and explain to them why we and these are the thing that by the mistake if they click on.
Yeah, yeah.
If they click on this part, I would say...
I'm not sure they share it with client or not. I hope no.
It's an internal note, right? So that would not go, yeah.
Yeah, it's internal, yeah, OK.
But it has no good vision.
And, unfortunately, it happens only with your technician, the right way design technician. No one, no one use this kind of, I don't wanna use some words, the blur.
So rather, just a quick thing.
Yeah. Is there a recurring issue that you're seeing with the team or is it something that you've started to see?
Ah.
I think.
Since last week or two weeks ago I saw something like this.
And it's only, as I said, it's only ITBD by design technician.
Okay.
I'm not sure who gave them this kind of instruction. Might be, might we told them, yeah, go ahead and install and use AI, but we told them use AI. Don't put.
Some stuff which which has no make sense to the ticket.
Yeah, it seemed to be the search for the issue and everything that came on GPT it is but it was a complete copy paste of everything.
Yeah.
I'm glad that this was an internal node, else this would have gone out to the client.
Yeah, not Tanim.
Haley.
Oh yeah, they're all from my side, but it's not a simple issue.
Hey, everybody.
Ali.
It's A lot. We should fix it.
Do you all, just out of curiosity, and I just came in on the tail end of this, does MSP Corp have an acceptable use policy in place for AI?
Yeah, we do have we do have that and then I can share it with you. There is no issue to using AI. Totally fine to use AI. But what I'm saying is if we use AI, AI is our tool. We cannot use AI and copy and paste all this stuff.
Sure.
that AI has in a ticket and say, I can explain to you what happened really for this ticket and it's not only this ticket. I'm going to share my screen again.
Right.
Sure, before you, before you, and please, I'll allow you to in a moment, but I just, the reason I was asking is twofold. One, yes, I'd appreciate if you can share it with us. We are happy to reinforce that, right, to go over it with the team. Is this part of the, anyone who's coming on, is this part of their onboarding with your pod?
To use a choose AI, you say, or during the onboarding, during, I would say, during the meeting that we have weekly with them, Arkadi mentioned to them, go ahead and use AI if you, if you're looking for a technical.
Yeah.
guidance. It's totally fine for us, but how to use AI. It should be a part of your skill set. We're not going to train them about how to use AI.
I...
So I agree with you and I also will say if I have the new team member coming into my team, I'm going to double check and see what, you know, I'm going to share the policy and I'm going to make sure that some basics are just are just there. It might be even worth us talking about as a group.
evaluating just a couple of one question or two questions in the interview process, even if it's on our side when we're screening, right, to get an understanding of where they stand with some of these things now that these are so incorporated into the daily use. Because I agree with you, Reza, some of these are basics, right? The concept of copying, especially with like little emojis and...
and check marks and things like that, it makes it blatant, blatant. So even if all the content was 100% accurate, which I know your, I heard your question as to whether it was or not, noting that it wasn't related, right? Even if it was 100% accurate, I wouldn't want it to be presented in such a way where it made it so blatantly obvious that.
Mhm.
that they had leveraged it, right? It doesn't verify that they understand anything. So I'm just tossing that out there as part of the mic thing and concerns.
Mmh.
Your voice is breaking up.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's because I was, can you hear me again? I apologize. I was opening my headphone case and of course I was playing with it. And of course my phone thought that I wanted to switch and I did not. It was more a tick. But yeah, I just want to figure out, okay, what's our best?
Yep, yep.
Okay.
And.
Ohh.
It.
path to making sure that we're, that the engineers coming in are on the same page because they may not have come from environments where it was acceptable or they may, you know, just have limited access.
Dharam.
prior to it. I just, I think it's worth us level setting and we're happy to help on that front. I mean, you share your policy and we can go over that and of course, some of these basics with them. That's not a problem. Arkadi, I see your hand up in response, I'm sure.
Go ahead.
So the issue isn't really with the usage of AI as a tool of research or troubleshooting or anything else. The issue is with including not relevant information in an escalation forum, for example. So we have, in fact, most of the team utilizing AI in some way or another, to some extent or another.
Sure.
Right.
Yep.
Even I started to recently, right? It's just becoming our reality. That's not the issue. The issue is taking the output of those systems that you use to help you troubleshoot or research something, and then only grabbing the relevant stuff and including that in information that goes to the next team.
Yeah.
or to their own teammates or to me or to rather to Torren, right? So that, yeah, it's fine. It's fine to use AI if it helps you do your job faster and better. Again, it's just about the documentation part. And imagine if this was not an internal note, this went to the client. They would say,
Sure.
Okay, you're using AI to do our stuff? Like, why are we paying you? You know? So...
Yeah, yeah, and and and so remember that, so who who do they report to directly?
Do you, you, Jasper invention, and text next up to me, to me, to me, yeah?
The engineers, who do they report to directly on to you, Arkadi? Okay, yeah, I mean, I agree with you wholeheartedly, like I said, and we're happy to reinforce and go over some of these basics. This is part of why we have this call, right, is if you're experiencing...
if you're experiencing challenges, we want to make sure that we understand them and do whatever support we can. Is this beyond the one engineer or is this a habit you've seen across multiple engineers?
I've seen a few tickets of this now.
Yeah.
Okay.
Mhm.
And is this a challenge you have with other engineers in the pod that aren't through our group?
But.
No, we don't have any issue with them, and and the thing is, you know what, using it on its own is good, but but they are Helpdesk technician, they are level one, and they they have access to...
Okay.
Sure.
the history of tickets, they have access to senior engineering, senior technicians on our side, and also they have access to the document. And we have some obligation for them. Let's say one of the important obligations that we have for them is if you cannot fix the issue, regardless of the type of issue.
See.
And if you have no path to fix the issue, escalate it to escalation team, regardless of the type of issue, even if it is a simple reset password and you don't know that, we can figure it out later, but if it is a simple, if it is an issue, pass it there. But when I use AI, it means...
Sure.
I know something about that and I want to make sure that my pathway is accurate.
If I don't know anything about the issue, why we start researching? There is no research space for them. There is no room to research for Helpdesk technician. Helpdesk technician has a lot of tickets in their plate and they have to handle it.
So if it happens with one of my senior technician in escalation team, or if someone in project team does that, it's totally fine. They can go ahead, spend a lot of time to research, to find the solution for the issue. And I'm pretty sure that issue is.
complex issue, it's not as simple. But if you do research for this simple issue in AI, I reach to this point that it might be lack of knowledge, lack of skill set. It's my issue because I interviewed them and I should have interviewed them.
them better about their skill set. And the second part is your responsibility to train them about their technical stuff. And the third part is even if...
Forgive, forgive, when you say your responsibility, to whom are you referring?
I mean, ITI design.
Okay, okay, so one of the things I want to make sure we're really clear about, operational oversight and standard performance execution, that's day-to-day management of their outcomes. The agreement that you guys are in with us, that's you guys are on what we call self-managed, right?
Mmh.
So we're happy to help facilitate where we can, but the management of these types of outcomes are really tied to your service management processes. They're tied to your MSP Corp organizational preferences. Now, some of these baseline things, like I said, I take no issue with us taking back and saying, hey, yeah.
Mhm.
We can we can help support that effort, but I just want to make sure we're on the same page as far as as far as where that responsibility lives.
Yeah, it's totally fine. In terms of process-wise, day-to-day management, we do that. No issue on that. But far as we can recall, in one of our meeting, it was Ashish or one of you guys asked me to share the knowledge that they need in terms of.
Technical, and I'm not sure Arkadi shared it. My assumption is, if I share some topics for you guys, you're gonna have some training for for the technician to say, "Okay, we need these kind of we need these kind of technical skill set in in your side, so it would be your responsibility to train them."
If it is our responsibility, it's okay. We can handle it that we do day to day, but we have limited of time to spend for technician. We should rely, we should rely at least on one part of their skill set. When you handle a ticket, you need to have, you need to have.
Yeah.
You need to do two different things. First, communication, and the second is a technical part of that.
Mhm.
Tactical drive, yep.
If I cannot rely on their communication style that I showed the team on the previous ticket, and I cannot recall on the technical part of those, what is the benefit of having them?
Right.
Yeah, yeah, and and this is the...
You know what I mean? This is the part and I'm not here to decline them. I'm here to fix the issue. I'm here to say, okay, take the responsibility of one part that you are familiar with, which is the technical part. We're going to take the responsibility of the communication and process wise.
And together, we're going to fix this issue. Unless you say no, it's not my responsibility. I'm going to prepare the, I'm going to give you the resource, and it's your responsibility to handle it. And I say, OK, don't worry about that. I would try on.
on this technician and if I reach to the point that no, there is no way to help them to understand the technical part. There is no way to help them to understand the communication part. So it's a decision point for me to make a decision.
Right, right, and honestly, there is a balance that we'll have to strike there, right? We don't have a dedicated technical team lead for you all, and this is something that we've brought up, right? Not not with you, but as a as a holistic topic, somebody like that takes that on us and and really drives it and actually owns it, not just.
And.
in part, like we can do now, but because Ashish is a shared resource, Amit, myself, Sarbjeet, we're account representatives, we're here to support, right? But none of us own it explicitly either, right? Based on the agreement. So it's one of those things where I want to make sure.
Okay.
Aaron.
And.
Ohh.
You know, like I said, we're happy to help collaborate on it. Reza Arkadi, Torin, I'm not shying away from helping. I just want to make sure that when, as we're hitting rd bumps, we're our eyes are all open. Oh, this, there's going to be bad.
Mhm.
Yeah.
risk of bandwidth issues like you said on your side, etc. On our side, we want to make sure we're doing what we can to help with it, right? So again, setting up a training for acceptable use policy, easy, right? For us, right? We can get it done. Going over some of these basic communication things.
Okay.
And.
Yeah, absolutely. If there are basics that are missing, what I want to make sure we're doing, what I'm more inclined to worry about is as we're looking at the resources, right person, right C, and as you guys expand, I want to make sure, like you said, Reza, you know, we haven't made the wrong choice.
Mhm.
Mmh.
with the selection process, that the selection process is up to speed enough where, yeah, this is a person's going to be a cultural fit and they've got the communication and technical chops to live in this pod successfully. That's going to be, I think, the long-term solution here is that.
Yeah.
Yeah, and we do have, for what it's worth, we've actually added a couple of things to our onboarding for your group specifically already, based on we had added a security policy item. Arkadi, thank you so much. We'll speak again soon. No, no worries. And a couple of other things. So we don't take issue.
Kip.
with doing it. If you send that over, what we can do is in addition to your specific policy, we can draft around some of those communication basics that we're talking about. Like, hey, if you're going to use AI, validate and.
don't copy paste, right? Like those were two pretty standard basic thoughts for those of us on the call maybe. But like I said, if I'm trying to, if I put my shoes into a green engineer who's, you know, who maybe didn't have that luxury of being able to use it.
Yeah.
six months ago with their last job or whatever. I wanna give some some room for acknowledging. OK, well, let's just show you the way, right? It's these are simple ideas. Once we've once we've established them for people, usually they don't. They don't then.
Mhm.
Make the same error multiple times, so...
Yeah, yeah, the thing is, I, yeah, it's good that we clear about these steps, 'cause you know, at the end.
My decision is hire more technician from IT by design. And it's a policy that we have in our BU. But in other hand, in other hand, I should care about my clients because at the end,
Yeah.
I'm responsible about MRR. And MRR comes from their action, comes from the client happiness, client satisfaction. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hundred percent.
Trust me, we get it. Yeah, yeah, no Reza heard. Go ahead, go ahead.
Okay, this is the part, but what I'm thinking is, because you know, based on our meeting that we have, weekly, bi-weekly meeting, I really, I trust you guys. I trust you guys, because you know, when you say.
Leave the technical part on me. I would say, okay, no problem. The technical part is on you. Go ahead. This is a list of things that we need a technician knows as a basic standard thing. We're going to train them about the specific application, the specific environment that our client has.
There is no way for you guys to handle it. It's on our side. But in terms of process, definitely it's in our side. We handle all the process day-to-day stuff with them. But something is not for process and not for technical. Something is.
Right, right.
basic day-to-day thing that you should think about that. I share the ticket before you join to the meeting.
I, I, I caught the tail end of it, yeah, I saw, I saw what was written on it, yeah, no, it, it's why I'm rolling my eyes on the tail.
Yeah, yeah, that, that, what was that? We started communication with user ticket handover to two different technicians, and then we sent out a communication to Kleiner and said, all the...
preliminary steps have completed and client back to me and said, what did you do for me? Just regardless of the issue, I'm just wondering what did you do for us? And I have no, I have nothing to explain to them. It's not about come.
Yeah.
Right.
It's not about technical, it's not about high level communication step. It's about understanding, yeah, electrical thinking, being smart.
Logical thinking, yep.
Yeah, yeah, no, heard, heard. Amit, Ashish, I know you guys are on board with this. We have some stuff in mind. I think what we can do is we can take, when Reza shares their AUP around AI, we can take that.
Yeah, we get it, we get it.
along with some of these communication gaps and maybe leverage that within as like a subsection of like a standard, like an SOP communication ticket handling, a refresher for many of our MSP Corp engineers, I'm sure.
Kour.
But even then, it'll maybe shed some light and for some of these who might be operating under false impressions of how they should can be operating, it'll give them clarity on on what good looks like. So why don't we do that?
Mm.
Okay, cool. So let's recap it. In terms of technical side, what should you do for us?
Reza, just one thing before I get into the recap mode. So the conversation that we had on the previous call around you let us know the name of the technology or the part of the technology which Arkadi was supposed to share with us, right? Where?
The.
you think it will benefit the engineers if they are retrained right through the ITBD internal training team or any other training means that we have available that will benefit them technically, we are still up for it. I mean, that's a part of our internal exercise, right, wherein.
Mm.
we ensure that any training needs are fulfilled. So one help that we would still need that we wanted to move this very quickly, to be honest, because we didn't want to spend a lot of time. So if we can have this expedited, get us the list right where, which all technologies these guys need to be trained on.
and we can still get them moving. That will benefit us, as in, of course, your team, and in terms of how they're dealing with certain issues. So that is one thing on us. As soon as we have received that detail, we will get this thing moving. Talking about the logical thinking part, I think that requires A recalibration.
Mm.
Okay.
that we will take away as an action and speak to the team to make sure that they understand the difference between a copy paste and because at the end of the day, AI can give you the output, but you still need the human brain to validate what is right and what is wrong. So that part was completely missing. We recognize based on.
the examples that is shared that we are going to take away, like Lee said, that will certainly go at cascade and make sure that team understands, right? And certainly we'll observe. One last question that I'll ask, right? And it is completely what we have learned over the time.
Right, that there are people, you know, we invest our time on and we know that they are moving in the right path, right? And they are the right fit for the team. And what we understood based on the last couple of feedback that Vansh has started moving in the right path, right? Jesper, I think, was doing pretty okay. Paxton and Jimmy are pretty new, so I will exclude them from the list.
Are we?
at a stage, Reza, where you want to give up on.
any one of these resource to say, Amit, it'll be good to have somebody else to invest their time on because they probably are willing, but they are not the right fit. Where it is important that we calibrate it at the right time so that your efforts and time.
And of course, your customer experience is not compromised because we are still trying to give them time. We recognize that. We probably will take them to training and internal processes and find a better place for them. But at the same time, it is also important for us to understand from you, and I'm keeping it really straight and transparent, right? If you think.
Okay.
that I probably would want to have somebody else taking this place, right? We can happily go ahead, find a resource equally skilled, right? And probably, you know, we can start looking at a transition plan. Of course, we're not going to take them out. You will have an overlap period.
But we certainly would prefer that as well.
Yeah, it's a hard question because, you know, when I'm thinking about all the effort that we put for this technician to somehow turn them to the good situation based on our, based on our standards.
Yeah.
You can recall 4 weeks ago, we had a conversation about one of the technicians, and I told you guys that I'm going to give him two weeks to make sure that our decision is right or wrong. And frankly speaking,
Based on what you advised to that technician and what happened in our site, he did some changes in his site. He changed the type of communication, he changed the type of...
fixing the issue, he moved to the better way of handling technical parts. But if I want to compare, because you know, it's not a good point that I say, okay, well, we go ahead and replace this one with that one, because I don't know how.
the new technician, who is the new technician? What's the level of that new technician? Should I put again four months to train them about this stuff? And then we have a technician same as what we have now, or it's the best way to focus on the training part, help them to understand our process, help them to understand the...
technical stuff of thing and turn them to the next level, level up their skill set, level up their communication part. And the reason why I say, okay, I'm gonna ask you guys to focus on these.
skill set that you can handle it in your side. And the thing that you, it's out of your control and we can handle it in our side. We're going to focus on that is kind of like work as a team to level up them to be.
be it as a part of our standard, be a part of our standard technician. So there is no yes and no for that, for your question. So I would say still we can try on them, still we can try on them, because you know.
I see the gross pass up there, if...
No, I appreciate that transparency, Rozario. I mean, like I said, the right that we, you have our full support in the background in terms of, and we have been talking about this pretty much every week, right? And we, as you can see, that there is a lot of focus from our side as well. So as much as we understand that operationally, you're managing it, but at the same time, you know, any other additional support,
Mmh.
which is needed, like about the training and cascading them about the AI usage, like Lee mentioned, right? We are certainly gonna take, go ahead and take those actions too. But I also at the same time wanted you to be at ease where you can tell me, Amit, you know what? Let's start.
Let's start looking for somebody who can be a better fit because we also value your time and effort that you're putting in and we don't want to be in a position that you're putting so much of effort. And then you probably realize that, you know, why did we put so much of effort? Somebody who's not generating that result.
So if we see they're moving in the right direction, and if you want to give it a time, we are all in for it. Yeah, my request would still remain that, you know, if I can please have the list of the trainings or refresher trainings, it may be the case they already know it, but we still want them to be trained again one more time.
Yeah.
Mhm.
to make sure that we have covered everything that is required to be covered, right? And you also have the confidence that, you know what, these people have gone through everything and let's make a reassessment of the same.
Pre.
Yeah, sure, yeah, it's a good idea. And it's a part of our company, I would say, culture. We try a lot in our technician, even if they fail on some part. We try a lot on them because we believe we believe that.
Sure.
App.
By training, we can handle everything if we forget on the training, if you, if you...
Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, Jeremy.
And if you selected smart, right, hungry, humble, smart, those are the three things that we're all looking for. If you selected wisely on those 3 parameters, then you're right. One of the things, just to second what Amit said, you know, we're all in on figuring out what the right method is.
Yeah.
We just see too many people get stuck in sunken cost fallacy, not you guys specifically, but others, and we want to make sure, you know, if we've opened the wrong door and walked in, we don't need to take a seat, right? We need to figure out, oh, okay, let's go find the right door.
Mm.
Haha.
Now, if these are like little things and like, like you said, Reza, I'm glad to hear, you know, hey, we spoke with them, we worked on X, Y, and Z on this side of house, ITBD did this, MSP Corp did this, and we're seeing improvement. Awesome. What we want to make sure is that we say, one, you know, the door is open for that.
to the perspective from the engineers. If it's not right fit, you know, our objective will be to try to find them another project. It's not going to be like you're firing somebody in the same way that you would in another type of relationship, even though we say, you know, like incorporate them like they are your own, because they essentially are.
Yeah.
This is one of those little nuances that's very helpful because it removes a lot of the stigma and resentment. Oh, okay, that project wasn't quite the right one. We can move them along. The biggest thing for me is probably the same biggest thing for you. I don't want you to have to repeat efforts again and again because I know the time, effort, and cost.
Mm.
And.
of bringing on a new team member. So obviously, that's why I say our strongest opportunity is just making sure that the playbook we operate on to bring in new team members as we move forward, whether it's a replacement or a net new, is really, really strong, and that the group of us are all on the same page about what
Yeah.
And so some of these little. Pain points that we're seeing, you know, we're we're all assuming these are basics, but if we can capture them and catch them early on in in our interview process, great, all the better we can avoid getting some or.
Mhm.
Dubey.
or even in the onboarding training, just cover some of these, hey, I don't know what you were doing in the past. Here's what's acceptable here. Here's what's not, right? So that's my thought process.
Yeah, all right. Yeah, I think now we are on the same page. So we're going to focus on training again. And I'm going to share that technical things with you. If you want, I can share the process-wise as well, but I'm pretty sure it's too hard for you guys to deep dive to the process and training them.
Yeah, it gets tricky depending on how much of it's nuanced and MSP Corp or MSP Corp client specific, yeah.
It's the right job.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, let's focus on the parts that we can easily handle in each side, so...
Policy is great. Yeah, policy is great. Communications is great. Things like that. Yep.
Yeah.
Oh yeah, yeah, okay, cool. I think how, yeah, after our meeting, I'm going to speak with Arkadi. We already have that list. It needs a little bit adjustment. And after that, we're going to share it with you. And we can target another two weeks for this technician.
The access, their access, their effort, your effort, our effort, to see what what would happen.
Key.
Yeah.
Kip.
Thank you. Thank you. I mean, I think it has been a valuable chat, always speaking to Reza, you, and of course, Arkadi, every time we've spoken to you. I guess, you know, as we try to, as a final note from our side, as we try to settle in the engineers in your environment, of course, you know, we are getting the cadence of what is needed.
Thank you, guys.
And that is, that'll help us bring more experienced engineers, if that at all becomes a requirement in future, right? So, to recalibrate things, but yeah, hopefully that we are moving in the right direction. Bexton is a MSP experienced engineer that he have started with, so hopefully you know he he will.
Okay.
All right.
Yep.
take away a lot of things as a learning and the mistakes which others have made to make sure that he's not repeating those and your experience overall continues to improve.
Yeah, definitely. It's a good point. Thank you. Thank you, guys, and...
Yeah.
I think.
Thank you, thank you, Dorian.
Thank you, Rezab. Thank you, Tony.
Thanks, Kris.
Thank you. Thanks, everyone.
We're good to stop here. Bye.
Pleasure seeing y'all. Cheers.
Cheers, bye.
Bye.
Okay.